wood has apparently now deleted the now
Infamous Pro Taliban video which he
posted the calls all the problems as a
result of me telling him to delete it so
there you go uh feminist author Caitlin
Moran made headlines last week by
blasting Dr Jordan Peterson telling GQ
that she fears for any man under crisis
turning to him the fact is that many men
in crisis do turn to him and to others
with similar messages in a culture that
seems beset by anxiety problems and
epidemic of trauma a simple message of
discipline has found massive resonance
but blaming mental health seems to be a
fig leaf for all manner of celebrities
sin so I'll be living through a mental
health crisis or I'll be living through
a crisis of not having mental strength
joining me now is rapper and podcaster
zubi and the author and broadcaster
Jenny Cleveland right welcome to both of
you zuba you've been very strong about
this you said a lot of uh tough stuff I
would call it tough love and it comes
from a place of wanting to help people
but you think that there's basically a
lot of people who use Mental Health
perhaps in the way that it used to be
stigmatized now in a way as a sort of in
a glorifying manner yeah I think it's
pretty nuanced I think that there is
genuinely a decline in overall mental
health and mental well-being especially
amongst younger people and we could get
into the reasons for that at the same
time there is also an element of
trendiness that is going on with it in
certain infections on the opposite end
and then I think on top of it as well
it's become
huh what's the best way to put this
um I think there is also that yes there
is an absence of resilience in that
people are not being as well prepared
for the World perhaps as they should be
and I think another thing that's going
on is this sort of pathologizing of The
Human Condition I call it which is
calling sadness depression calling a
pain or a heartbreak trauma
um calling just sort of using this
therapy language all of a sudden you
have teenagers who are claiming they
have PTSD and everyone's got trauma and
anxiety and depression and I think these
words are being overused and so that's
why I have a lot of agreement with a lot
of that uh Jenny I think the problem is
that people I think who've got real
mental illness
to build about mental health and I find
that weird it's like well mental health
if you're healthy aren't you mental
illness means you're sick and need
attention and help in a clinical
depression is a very serious thing and
so on but I do I've seen a real Trend in
a lot of famous people who seem some of
them seem to have endless things wrong
with them which then become front page
news or books or whatever it may be and
I the cynic in me says really you're all
suffering from all these things from
your Mansions well maybe they are
suffering from it maybe in the past
people felt that they couldn't talk
about it and I think I think the
destigmatizing of these kinds of
problems is a good thing it is still the
case that um you know suicide is the
leading cause of death of men under 50.
um and it is a good thing that we are
getting better at telling people there's
nothing to be ashamed about if you if
you have these problems I'd agree though
that um I do think we we have a problem
where we are not encouraging people to
be resilient some of the most rewarding
things I've done in my life have been
daunting have been tough where I've had
to put myself out of my comfort zone and
I do think we need to encourage people
to I think there's a disconnect between
like if you take sport professional
sport right people are conditioned to be
incredibly mentally strong resilient
tough I don't know why we don't
transport that to regular life get into
schools with tough people going in there
and and trying to teach people mental
strength and resilience they're actual
things that you can be taught you can be
taught to be tougher and stuff but if
you talk in this language I'll
immediately have people reacting now on
Twitter right you're disgusting you're
inhuman no no I've brought up four kids
I've had lots of intense conversations
with them from time to time about very
difficult times in their lives and tried
to help them through it I'm a good
listener I think I encourage people to
talk all that is is fine but I also did
say it's a generational issue of young
people who just don't seem as equipped
to deal with normal life and I think
zombie that a lot of what you're saying
it may sound like tough stuff it's a
tough love in a way we want people to to
be better I don't think they're being
equipped to come out of school perhaps
and have the skills set for life yeah
absolutely and I think the the truth is
that the world is difficult life is hard
at a minimum every single person we know
and love including ourselves we're all
gonna die we're all going to experience
we all have a terminal illness sickness
right we're all going to experience
tragedy and that's just the way of the
world you're also going to come across
people you disagree with you're going to
hear things you don't like your good
people are going to be nasty to you and
harsh and so on and sure we shouldn't go
around being nasty and harsh towards one
another but you also have to recognize
if you're gonna if you're a teenager if
you're a young adult if you're going to
exist in the world with the 8 billion
people in it and all its complexities
you have to be strong and resilient I
totally agree and the thing is people
can mock people like Jordan Peterson and
Andrew Tay let's put aside the court
case we'll see what happens with that
when we're on an interview I did say
afterwards I found myself agreeing with
a lot of what he was saying you may not
like the way he says it and some of it
is unacceptable but we've got a clip of
one of the things you said example
do you believe depression is a real
thing I believe that feeling depressed
is real I don't believe depression as a
clinical disease is real no a lot of
people who are clinically depressed are
suffering with something in their life
and if you fix the problem in their life
perhaps they won't feel depressed but
it's not a disease but Andrew that's
situational Andrew You're simply wrong
if you think you are single-handedly
curing people of clinical depression you
are living in Cloud curcula so that's
one of the issues I had with it was I
think he goes too far with that I think
clinical depression is a very real
sickness that needs proper treatment but
there are other parts of that interview
where he talked you know and the reason
that young men in particular gravitate
to the likes of Tate and Jordan Peterson
and others and they're different
characters
um with different skill sets but they
these guys do try and give them a
message of empowering them to feel
stronger about life is that wrong I mean
masculinity is not everything masculine
is not toxic apparently I think that's
very damaging problem with that approach
though is it gives the impression that
these issues are easy to solve if you
man up and pull your socks up and if you
can't solve these problems by you know
getting out of bed making your bed and
you know exercising then um you you have
failed and you are weak and it could be
incredibly damaging for someone who's in
real crisis who's hearing that the
solutions are simple what I'm feeling
isn't real I need to just go and do that
but actually there's a great speech by
Admiral mcraven the great U.S Navy Navy
SEAL commander and he does the making
your bed speech he did a commencement
thing where he talked about if you just
get up in the morning whatever your
problems are and you make your bed and
you make it well it's a great start to a
day yeah and it's a great speech I
recommend people go and watch it because
I do think it's doing the basic stuff in
life bringing a bit of discipline in
order for your life in real Christ no no
I'm not talking about people who have a
genuine mental illness I'm talking about
the vast ways of people who just seem to
find life difficult now and exactly this
is why it's important for people to use
words correctly yeah right I was talking
before about what I call label inflation
if you're just feeling sad and you say
that you're depressed and you have
depression if you're a little bit
worried and concerned about things and
you're saying that you have anxiety
PTSD and so on you're you're diluting
these terms so now it becomes more
difficult to separate someone who's just
feeling sad because their life is not
going well and they don't have certain
things in order versus someone who
genuinely has agreements we've got to
leave it there sadly it's interesting
debate it won't go away we'll have it
again in more depth but it's an
interesting debate I just want young
people to feel a bit more resilient and
strong because they'll enjoy their lives
more and I think social media has a lot
to do with why they don't and that's
another part of this which we didn't get
into great to see you both zubie and I
had a good old bust up on Twitter
earlier about covert haven't got time
for that tonight but we won another time
zoomy I'm coming for you okay don't
worry I'm ready I'm ready uh good to see
you